good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight here's some bracing news we
never expected to report black lives
matter is now more popular than the
President of the United States and not
slightly more popular than the president
much more popular a survey this week by
Rasmussen a right-leaning pollster found
that 62% of likely voters now have a
favorable opinion of black lives matter
the same time Rasmussen found that
Donald Trump's approval rating was 43%
that's almost 20 points lower
and by the way Trump was not alone black
lives matter is far more popular than
Joe Biden is - it's more popular than
America's religious institutions all of
them it's more popular than the media
the Congress and big business black
matters is more popular by double digits
than both the Democratic and the
Republican parties it's almost as
popular as the US military it's much
more popular than the Pope the numbers
are astounding but the polls are not the
only measure of it here's a black lives
matter rally from over the weekend in
New York look at that picture that is an
ocean of people ask yourself the last
time you saw a candidate for office who
was able to draw a crowd like that the
media in their relentless ly fawning
coverage usually described black lives
matter as an activist group or a protest
movement but that's deception by
understatement black lives matter is not
a collection of marchers with signs it's
not a conventional political lobby like
Planned Parenthood where the NRA it's
not pressuring Congress to pass some
narrow new set of laws black lives
matter is far more ambitious than that
it is working to remake the country and
then to control it it's a political
party as it tonight black lives matter
may be the single most powerful
political party in the United States
nobody says that out loud but
politicians understand it perfectly well
if nothing else they understand power
they can smell it at great distances and
that's why they're lining up to bow
before black lives matter you can't
really reform a department that that is
rotten to to the route we've heard our
people cry out I can't breathe
we've heard our people speak out black
lives matter this is a system this is a
systemic problem that requires a
comprehensive solution and what I would
say is that there is there's a
legitimacy to this anger there's a
legitimacy to this outrage none of what
you just saw is a stretch for Democrats
they believe their long term goals
aligned with those of black lives matter
and in fact at times the group functions
as an arm of the Democratic Party more
telling though and more ominous is the
response from any Republicans they've
been happy to go along as well or in
Mitt Romney's case even mouthed the same
slogans violence and brutality and to
make sure the people understand that
black lives matter that was the former
Republican nominee for president let
that sink in if there was ever an
indicator of how powerful black lives
matter has become you just saw it
Republican leaders brag about their
strong conservatives convictions but
mostly they just want to be on the
winning team whatever that is that's why
they pause before offending China it's
why when black lives matter tells them
to take a knee they do it's all pretty
strange when you think about it if the
leaders of black lives matter are
political actors and they are then by
definition you were allowed to have any
opinion you want to have about them
black lives matter wants to run the
country therefore you can freely
criticize black lives matter those are
the rules of our system but not anymore
imagine a world where you are punished
for questioning the behavior of the
President or for insulting your local
mayor you probably can't imagine that
it's too bizarre it's on American but
that's where we are right now black
lives matter has changed the rules and
here's their first new rule no
criticizing black lives matter you can
be fired from your job if you disobey
many Americans have been on Friday for
example the principle of a public school
in Windsor Vermont was dismissed from
her job for posting the following words
on her personal Facebook page quote
while I understand the urgency to feel
compelled to advocate for black lives
what about our fellow law enforcement
just because I don't walk around with
the BLM signs should not mean I'm a
racist end quote unfortunately the
principal's boss disagreed the shoe
Intendant of windsor schools describe
the quote you just heard as quote
outright racist ones are Vermont by the
way is more than 97% white also on
Friday an economist called Harold uhlig
lost his job at the Federal Reserve Bank
of Chicago for daring to offer even
milder criticism than that on Twitter
uhlig noted that black lives matter had
quote just torpedoed itself with its
full-fledged support of hashtag defund
the police now is the time uhlig noted
quote for sensible adults to enter back
into the room and have serious earnest
respectful conversations about it all
that was a racist statement the Federal
Reserve concluded so they fired Harold
yulik we could give you many other
examples of the same thing happening
there are a lot of them black lives
matter now enjoys almost complete
immunity from criticism this is
unprecedented for an American political
movement but black lives matter is even
more powerful than that it is
single-handedly revised our moral flame
framework yes black lives do matter that
is a statement of fact and no decent
person doubts that it is true because it
is and it's true precisely because every
life matters we are all human beings
every one of us we have souls skin color
is irrelevant to moral value until
recently this was considered obvious
saying it was regarded as a virtue all
lives matter equally all of us were
created by God in the end all of us will
die nothing can change that not wealth
not Fame not race every life is
precisely as valuable as every other
life by the way that idea forms the
basis of the Christian faith is the
entire premise behind our founding
documents and yet suddenly thanks to
black lives matter you can no longer say
it out loud affirming the fundamental
equality of all people is now considered
hate speech you can be fired for saying
it again many people have been this is a
dangerous moment how do we get here in a
word quickly it happened fast as
recently as December before the riots
most Americans did not approve of black
lives matter the group was defined in
the public mind by moments like this
pigs in a blanket fry like bacon kill
the police they yelled that at a rally
the usual liars immediately swooped in
to pretend that it never happened the
president of the Southern Poverty Law
Center wrote an entire op-ed ordering
the public not to consider black lives
ladder matters a hate group but people
could see the truth for themselves the
video was online a lot of facts about
black lives matters still reside on the
Internet they have not yet been scrubbed
the group's signature demand is to
eliminate law enforcement when you first
heard protesters scream defund the
police
it may have shocked you that's just
crazy you may have thought a few weeks
later support for eliminating law
enforcement is rising quickly in the
polls Minneapolis is already doing it
other cities will follow are you
surprised
almost no one in public life has pushed
back meaningfully against the idea of
defunding the police the black lives
matter position is the only position
most people hear after awhile they
believe it
unchallenged claims must be true that's
what most people assume and why wouldn't
they assume that if you strongly
disagree with something say so otherwise
it's much more likely to happen so with
that in mind consider some of the other
positions black lives matter has
endorsed the repeal of all immigration
restrictions for starters therefore that
the legalization of sex work
prostitution therefore that to the
destruction of the nuclear family your
family the forced reallocation of
farmland raced based reparations
specifically quote in the form of a
guaranteed minimum livable income for
all black people here that all black
people not just the descendants of
American slaves this would include the
millions of African and Caribbean
immigrants who on average now earned
more than native-born Americans every
one of these new Americans would receive
a guaranteed annual income from American
taxpayers or to atone for the sin of for
the sin of what actually allowing them
to immigrate here black lives matter
does not explain that part no one asked
them you could be fired for asked
which you cannot be punished for however
is looting and burning at least not if
your black lives matter huge parts of
our urban landscape have been destroyed
in the past month almost no one has been
held to account for it just the opposite
you're not you're encouraged to pretend
it never happened in st. Louis every
rider arrested has been released without
charges in New York hundreds were
released without bail same in Washington
DC it's happening almost everywhere and
not just in places controlled by elected
Democrats which tells you a lot for
where Texas for example is one of the
few major American cities that is led by
a Republican mayor Betsy price on May
31st a crowd of black lives matter
demonstrators blocked a bridge in
downtown Fort Worth when police arrived
to disperse them they threw rocks and
bottles of bleach three police officers
were injured
the mob then went on to loot and
vandalized businesses dozens of riders
were arrested for this ten days later
the city's police chief ed Kraus
announced that he was dropping all
charges against them crafts issued a
statement suggesting that the real
criminals in the riot were not the
rioters but his own police officers whom
he suggested would be reined in and
perhaps punished quote this is just one
step on a long journey Kraus wrote
sounding more like a therapist than a
cop but she promised that his department
was quote committed to walking the path
of reform with our community Krauss
never bothered to explain exactly what
his cops had done wrong they were cops
that was enough that same day the Fort
Worth School Board issued a statement
declaring that quote police practices
are deeply rooted in white supremacy
once again no one specified which police
practices reflected white supremacy or
what that accusation even meant it was a
blanket condemnation but it was left to
hang in the air as usual no one in
authority pushed back against it in a
republican-led City it'll be interesting
to know what happens to the murder rate
in Fort Worth over the next year we can
guess we're seeing it all over the
country we've seen it many times for the
years when the people in charge
undermine the law violence surges but
there is a solution to this vortex and
it's called leadership 65 years ago
politicians throughout the American
South refused to submit to the supreme
courts Brown versus Board
decision authorities in many states
simply ignored the law like it didn't
exist armed extremists groups filled the
vacuum they used violence to make their
own laws ultimately the federal
government stepped in and restored order
in 1957 President Dwight Eisenhower
federalized the National Guard of
Arkansas he sent troops to Little Rock
to force governor Orval Faubus to obey
the law so the question is where is our
Justice Department today right now is
there a reason the DOJ hasn't filed
federal conspiracy charges against the
people who organized and led these riots
it's not as if we don't know who they
are their crimes are on YouTube you know
the reason black lives matter was
involved it is politically sensitive no
prosecutor wants to be called a racist
as if it's racist to punish people for
crimes they committed you wonder what
the victims of those crimes think the
old people who were beaten to the ground
for trying to defend their property the
shop owners whose life savings were
stolen or burned the families of the
people who were murdered during the
riots and there were quite a few of them
no one is defending these people
no one is punishing their attackers
nobody cares imagine how they feel about
that what recourse do they have do they
have to torch a Wendy's or loot a
Walmart to get our attention
what's hoping on it might be enough to
have a single national leader just one
who understands what is actually going
on in this country and is brave enough
to say so
that might make all the difference and
it would certainly make the political
career of the person who does it in the
fall of 1968 a teaching assistant San
Francisco State University called George
Murray gave a speech endorsing racial
violence murray urged black students to
bring guns to campus and quote kill all
the slave masters murray by the way was
the quote Minister of Education in the
local Black Panther Party which was the
antifa
of its time when administrators learned
about Murray speech they equivocated but
ultimately they suspended him under
pressure in response to this a group
called the third world Liberation Front
shut down the campus sound familiar
they demanded the university drop all
admission standards for black applicants
and admit students purely on the basis
of race administrators were paralyzed in
the face of this more than anything they
didn't want to be called
racist the university's president was so
terrorized by it that he quit and left
ultimately the leadership of San
Francisco State fell to an unlikely
president a Japanese Canadian academic
called si Hayakawa Hayakawa was short
eccentric wore thick glasses but he was
completely fearless on December 2nd 1968
Hayakawa marched into the middle of a
student protest rioters immediately
assaulted him but Hayakawa kept going he
climbed onto the roof of a sound truck
and ripped the wires out of the
loudspeaker San Francisco State
University reopened that day so here's
the lesson for today's officeholders si
Hayakawa became a folk hero for standing
up to the mob he was elected to the
United States Senate from California
Republicans supported him voters did too
they didn't always understand him
Hayakawa wore a Scottish Tam O'Shanter
cap in public and never really explained
why he did but it didn't matter he was
brave and honest and voters appreciated
that above all they always do we don't
have our Hayek Cowell yet instead we
have cowards our leaders are happy to
talk about everything but the collapse
of the centuries-old civilization
tumbling down around them they have no
idea how little credibility they have
they have no sense of how irrelevant
they have become if you can't tell the
truth when if the truth actually matters
then nothing you say matters meanwhile
black lives matter becomes more powerful
and more popular with the public why is
that happening exactly here's why
because black lives matter is getting
exactly what they want and that is the
most basic sign of strength strength is
the most appealing quality to voters and
to people and to animals
three weeks ago black lives matter
demanded that cities defund their police
today the mighty NYPD the biggest police
department in our nation the most
sophisticated Police Department in the
world bowed and announced it is
abolishing its entire plainclothes
division 600 people gone for good
because black lives matter wanted it
done and now it is done that's not
bluffing it's not posturing it's not
tweeting that is real power you'll
notice it did not require the usual
maneuvering for black lives matter to
get that power they didn't need a team
of lawyers to get it black lives matter
doesn't make
legal arguments they're not trying to
convince you of anything black lives
matter believes in force they flood the
streets with angry young people who
break things and they hurt anyone who
gets in the way when they want something
they take it make them mad and they will
set your business on fire annoy them and
they will occupy your downtown and
declare a brand new country you're not
gonna do anything about it they know
that for certain this is the most
destructive kind of politics we've seen
a lot of it in recent years organized
groups did it to Brett Kavanaugh the
main point of slandering Cavanaugh was
never to block his confirmation we
misread that they knew they probably
couldn't achieve it the real point was
to send Cavanaugh and John Roberts and
the other Republican justices a very
clear message step out of line and we
will hurt your families and judging from
recent Court decisions it worked at
times it's very clear the supposedly
conservative justices are afraid to defy
them up so what message to the rest of
us
take from what's happened over the past
three weeks it's very simple the message
is force is more effective than voting
elections changed nothing rioting by
contrast makes you rich and powerful
when you riot prosecutors will ignore
the law on your behalf corporations will
send you millions politicians will kneel
down before you it works
violence works that's the message
everyone hears that message until
violence stops working violence will
continue how powerful is black lives
matter well for the left keeping their
protest going is more important than
fighting a deadly pandemic in the city
of New York officials are not even
allowed to ask if the people they are
surveying attended the protests which
may be spreading the virus an amazing
story next